there are always consequences to what we
create often unintended and some can
cause serious problems but sometimes
those unintended consequences are for
the best nowhere is this more true than
with our advancements in transportation
one early ride came to symbolize freedom
for an entire gender' Illinois 1893
Frances Willard the famous fighter
women's rights experienced the wind in
her face for the very first time on the
seat of a safety bicycle I think it's
hard for us to imagine today what it is
like to be literally trapped inside your
own house women were literally trapped
at home in the 19th century their
clothes trapped them because we're so
heavy they weighed up to 25 pounds and
they couldn't get about they were
dependent on a man to either put them on
a horse or put them in a carriage and
take them there
the bicycle offered them a way of
freedom how do you write it with great
courage and dexterity on which you are
very capable how do you pedal wearing
such cumbersome things carefully you
return she who succeeds in gaining the
mastery of the bicycle will gain the
mastery of life and the two things that
must occupy your thoughts to the
exclusion of everything else first the
goal indeed and today's goal will be
that plow okay then the first is the
goal and the second the momentum
requisite to reach it exactly don't look
down ain't directly
[Laughter]
[Music]
shame on you madam go home to your
husband
it's the same as with all reforms
sometimes they seem to lag then they
barely balance and away they go again as
merrily as if they never been stretching
to stop at all the freedom of movement
Frances Willard found her bicycle helped
her give her speech on time a speech
about another kind of freedom equal
rights for women and let them know the
world was made for women too
[Applause]
[Music]